- Ça suffit! Il ne faut pas
demander au peuple français de
se serrer encore la ceinture!- i
s'exprime au Havre en Normandie,
comme dans plusieurs villes à
travers le pays.
BÉATRICE ARROQUI, travailleuse
du secteur de l'enseignement
- Dans mon secteur, je pense
qu'on est touchés comme tout
le monde par les baisses de
salaire ou la non-augmentation
des salaires par rapport au coût
de l
- Des professionnels de
l'éducation, mais aussi de la
santé et des employés du port.
La manifestation longe la gare,
étrangement calme. Les cheminots
font aussi grève. En région,
seul un train sur deux circule.
Dans les rues, des appels à
de meilleurs salaires pour
affronter l'inflation,
mais aussi desquququques,
des réformes, comme la retraite
à 65 ans, défendue par le
président et son gouvernement.
DANIEL GRANCHER, retraité
- Il y en a marre que tous nos
présidents nous parlent qu'il
faut se serrer la ceinture,
qu'il faut faire des efforts,
que c'est fini l'abondance.
L'abondance, c'est pas pour
nous, c'est pour les r
Nous, notre abondance, c'est
simplement de regarder dans
le frigo si on peut finir la fin
de mois.
- Parmi les manifestants,
les travailleurs du secteur
pétrolier sont bien en vue.
Ce sont en quelque sorte eux
qui sont à l'origine de
ce mouvement de contestation.
Des employés des raffineries et
des dépôts de catstststs
du groupe Total Énergie font
grève depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant pour exiger
des augmens s s s de salaire.
Ce matin, un coup d'éclat :
les syndiqt t t t bloqué
certains accès à cette
raffinerie, la plus importante
du pays. Si d'autres syndicats
se sont entendus avec leur
employeur, ces travailleurs
de Total Énergie réclament
toujours une augmentation
salariale de 10 %, une manière
de pallier la hausse du coût de
la vie, mais aussi de toucher
une part des immenses
profits engrangés par le géant
pétrolier cette année.
JOHAN SENAY, secr. adj. syndicat
CGT, plateforme Normandie
a a a a peut-être un impact qui
est plus visible que les autres,
plus fort que les autres. On ne
va pas en rougir. Voilà.
La population doit comprendre
qu'on donne le "aiaiaiaintenant,
il faut qu'ils suivent.
- N'empêche, certains
commencent à perdre patience.
- Ça bloque tout le monde, et
puis vous voyez, l'affluence
qu'il y a partout. Donc,
puis ça commence à énerver
les gens, je pense.
- À la pompsisisisituation
s'est légèrement améliorée,
mais les pénuries perdurent.
Environ le quart des
stations-service françaises sont
toujours touchées.
- Pour pouvoir aller au travail,
conduire les enfants à l'école,
tout ça, c'est... ça va
devenir nécessaire.
- Cet autre automobiliste voit
aussi son quotidien perturbé.
- C'est vrai que pour les
automobilistes, c'est ennuyeux,
mais je soutiens totalement les
grévistes, quand on voit comment
les coûts ont augmenté.
- ( une manifestante): Il y en a
marre!
- Lui-même fonctionnaire,
il a justement pris part à la
mobilisation dans sa région.
Dans la foule, comme au sein
du gouvernement, une
question : la crise des
carburants a-t-elle déclenché
un mouvement soutenu de
contestation?
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada, Le Havr